[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable podcast
now also on YouTube as you can hopefully
see it's the weekly uh podcast brought
to you by the magazine free minds and
free markets I'm Matt Welch joined by
Nick Gillespie Peter sudman and
Katherine mangu Ward good morning
friendy howdy hi Matt happy Monday so
over the weekend uh our Once and Future
president Donald J Trump uh said on uh
Fox News with Maria bomo that he would
like to see a uh a 60%
60% tariff on all Goods coming from
China I'm not a mathematician but I
think what that means is that if you buy
the $500 China thing U it's now going to
cost $800 if that comes to fruition uh
Nick will check me up at halftime no I
really won't uh previously Trump has uh
talked about removing China from most
favored nation trading status which is
always hard to say in a row like that um
that would effectively be a 40% uh
tariff depending on how it all shakes
out plus he's been talking about a
universal Baseline tariff on everything
including the noncommunist countries um
of 10% uh across the board so Katherine
using your human voice can you explain
um to the crowd and including to people
who are kind of sympathetic or tariff
curious uh why uh you think this would
be a terrible idea the very very basic
answer to that question is it's just
going to make stuff cost more for
Americans and I don't really I can't
think of like other ways to convey that
idea because it seems like that should
be enough like hey we buy a lot of stuff
from China and if we did this uh
elaborate and punitive tariff uh plan um
we might buy a little bit less stuff
which is the goal according to tariff
backers we we should be less
economically engaged with China is sort
of fundamentally the idea here but we
wouldn't buy zero stuff we would still
buy quite a lot of stuff and that stuff
would be way more expensive and I don't
know if you know this Matt but a thing
that people are kind of worried about
right now in the economy in our weird
economy that I guess we're going to
maybe talk about later is stuff is
expensive the regular stuff that they
just buy uh feels like it is more
expensive than it should be there are a
bunch of reasons for that but a big one
is because we tax the stuff we put taxes
on the stuff um those taxes would not be
paid by an abstract idea that is
foreigners they would be paid by us and
I for one would not like to pay more for
my stuff I would just like to buy if we
put let's let's get the red Chinese out
of this for a second uh if we put a 10%
tariff on everything uh including the
friendy um uh doesn't that make it the
more likely for us to build our own
stuff and so then when we give money we
give it to Friendly Americans it would
make us more likely uh on the margins
that we would build our own stuff but um
we also have a whole bunch of rules in
this country that make that stuff really
expensive so um some of the things are
uh artificial like minimum wage laws uh
or um you know government imposers child
child labor laws labor loss uh some of
the things are just that we are a rich
country and so labor just costs a lot
more here but um the stuff that we might
make here it's true would be made here
but it would be more expensive stuff
still and sometimes it would be less
good stuff right like other countries
have people that are good at making
specific things that we're not great at
like semiconductors and we should buy
them from the people that can make them
uh well and cheaply Nick um there was a
reuter zipo poll last last August
showing that 66% of Americans said that
they would uh rather vote for a
president who wants to have even higher
uh tariffs against uh red China um if
Americans want higher tariffs you are
like the last guy since Barry Maguire
who insists on talking about red China I
love it so much every time Matt says it
it warms my robot I don't know
I they're Reds yeah uh but shouldn't the
federal government give Americans what
they want good and
hard no why not why there be more was
laying out and this by the way we can
focus on Trump and his trade Wars and
the the 10 10% Baseline tariff one thing
that is kind of interesting about that
and this is beyond economic theory it's
more political economy uh basically what
he's saying is he is going to any
country that has has a tariff on our
stuff he is going going to punish them
by doing the same tariff or Worse um and
that's kind of an interesting jawboning
exercise but you know one of the great
triumphs and Matt Welch you've written
about this endlessly um it seems like
you can't shut up about it in many
contexts but one of the great triumphs
of the past 30 40 years has been the
reduction in global tariffs um generally
speaking that has been a boon to people
in poor country countries and people in
wealthier countries so um you know
tariffs are ATT taxs as Katherine was
pointing out and they're not paid
they're not going to be paid by
communist Chinese uh you know party
members they're going to be paid by uh
workingclass people uh you know who have
the least amount of discretionary income
uh when you shop at Walmart and you know
90% of the stuff in Walmart probably
comes from China or pretty close that
all goes up by 60% and then all the most
of the other stuff is actually coming
from other countries so that goes up 10%
that's not I I don't think that's great
and it's not going to increase jobs so
that analysis when you increase exports
uh you increase jobs when you know so
and when you uh increase import you
generally increase buying power
purchasing power it's really remarkable
that after three and a half years of
griping about inflation Republicans are
preparing to nominate a man whose
signature policy would dram atically
raise prices for most Americans but
tariffs don't just raise prices for
Americans what they also do is hurt
American Producers and it is a uh a
somewhat forgotten fact that in 2018 and
28 and 2019 when Trump was uh initially
raising uh tariffs on some Chinese Goods
you had Trump also passed a $30 billion
bailout fund for American farmers so
that cost Americans money that was $30
billion because China put up retaliatory
tariffs so there's no such thing as a
one-way tariff this is why we call uh
trade Wars trade Wars is because one
country fires a a tariff shot and then
the other country fires a tariff shot
back and that is bad Wars are bad tariff
War uh trade Wars are bad and Trump
wants to start one very badly it appears
with China Peter a follow-up question if
uh you will if I will or if anyone will
um so in all the Articles it's not you
who Matt I think we know now when
question um if uh so in all these a lot
of
Articles globalist uh you know cuck
press out there and they've been
overwhelmingly negative about Trump and
tariffs uh and in paragraph 17 you'll
get to and Joe Biden since taking office
has largely kept Donald Trump's 2018
tariffs in place uh we're going to talk
about the afor mentioned weird economy a
little bit later but can you uh talk to
us just a little bit about what if any
daylight there is existing between Joe
Biden President Joseph robinet Biden the
third uh his tariff policy and Donald
Trump's the daylight that exists is that
Trump is uh proposing Draconian
ridiculous uh like Fantasy Land tariffs
of 60% like we mentioned earlier and I
don't see Joe Biden proposing that at
the same time Biden does seem to be uh
continuing the trade policy the Tariff
policy that was put in place under the
Trump Administration and I think we
would see maybe not a maybe not a sort
of a a nuclear trade War like we might
see under Donald Trump but a a kind of a
a trade War light a tra a proxy trade
War under Joe bidal weapons trade just
conventional West weapons right you know
a small War of the kind that Joe Biden
seems to be very much in the mood to
start the these days drones well and
Biden also is big on the bi Amer stuff
which is you know again to keep money
and dollars in Industry here and that's
also that has the bad effect of
making things cost smaller but also it
just means stuff doesn't get done you
know part of this Matt is and this is
kind of out of fashion but to talk about
things like comparative advantage where
you know do you want uh one of one of
the industries that has mostly gone
missing over the past 60 years in
America is the textile industry um and
do you really want your kids to grow up
to be like hooking carpets uh you know
is that your dream make America great
Again by bringing back chimney sweeps
and coal miner you know child coal
miners and stuff like that it's Loom we
should developments in uh economic
history we should be doing better higher
and higher level industry as well as
services and things like that and that
is part of you know this this has been I
think a failure on the part of uh
liberal economics or economists and
Libertarians as well as conservatives
who aren't idiots and a lot of liberal
including liberal progressives who will
do whatever they whatever they can for
uh union workers which often means uh
becoming protectionists but this it's a
better world when you can buy lots of
stuff from lots of different places and
uh you know people in America are not
working less in factories and More in
offices or you know whatever yeah so the
the Biden administration's trade policy
has often not been directly through
tariffs even though like I said they
have continued most of the Trump tariff
policy they have pushed industrial
policy through subsidies through uh
defense of the Jones act through uh
policies designed to promote encourage
or require Union work and that has made
everything more expensive as well
Katherine Nikki Haley uh your uh
Republican girlfriend um her uh Boston
marriage partner yeah exactly what's
Boston marriage partner mean that's when
the two spinsters live together yeah
matat figure it out mat God always the
last to
know Boston's like you know Liberace
just never found the right girl
God not wrong not inaccurate um so yeah
that is true actually I guess Nikki uh
Haley who's campaigning and competing
against Donald Trump uh is currently
behind by about 55 percentage points
Nationwide and 26 percentage points in
her home state of South Carolina which
has the next significant primary uh in
the calendar she's running against
Donald Trump's uh Terrace I'll read some
quotes what Donald Trump's about to do
is he's going to raise every household's
expenses by $2,600 a year I will push uh
she said and uh and like can you believe
he's going to do that and then she also
says about uh China I will push Congress
to revoke permanent normal trade
relations until the flow of fenel ends
if China wants to start normal trade
again it has to stop killing Americans
uh what is your uh take on the free
trade position inside the Republican
Party given those quotes seems like
maybe it's utterly incoherent and uh
will not be able to be implemented in
any meaningful way ever so there's that
um yeah obviously fenel not only um
poisons ual human beings sometimes very
horribly and trag tragically it has it
has utterly utterly poisoned our
discourse about everything right like it
should the idea that we are talking
about trade policy and that we slide
backwards right into fentanyl every time
we're talking about immigration policy
it's about fenel we're talking about I
don't know tax policy probably is
somehow about fentanyl I don't think
I've seen that move yet but like give it
time it's only February um the the idea
that that is a reasonable condition for
uh having you know open trade with any
nation is absurd but more importantly at
least someone is
saying sometimes the reasonable thing
she also just said this is going to
raise the cost of everything from baby
strollers to appliances this is the
truth right this is a very middle- class
families can't afford that she is
correct she is wrong about many things
including and I just feel compelled to
say this every time I say something nice
about her she is a horrific warmonger
who will result in dead babies etc etc
but uh and she's wrong about the making
F those babies carriages will be
slightly babies will
bees at least um so yeah this is this is
just a very very obvious economic
observation this is not some kind of
like highlevel point and it's
disappointing that so many people in
Washington who definitely know better
right like this is it's similar to the
um Mexico's going to pay for the wall
thing like I I truly believe that no one
who's ever said that sentence believes
that it's true um and the same is true
with these tariffs like it is is simply
not true that that the costs will be
borne only by foreigners even if they
were that it would still be bad policy
but that's not true anyway I think that
Steven Miller believes both of those
things um can we uh call fenel analog
Instagram no right because is it it
because Instagram is digital Instagram
is there by the yeah I think it's
actually Tik Tok that's digital fenol
and Instagram is like whatever the one
level down is Instagram is just digital
heroin and Tik Tok is digital fent
that's actually the the hierarchy that
people want you want Instagram is like
digital baking
powder digital Bing powder in a bagg
about the good things uh that uh Trump
has promised to enact if he comes in and
I was looking at this well uh he wants
to drill baby drill he he's very big on
getting back to an open energy policy
Nick I promise you I promise you we will
talk about drill baby drill when we talk
about drill baby drill but for this
episode when we're talking about trade
we're g talk about trade um oh I thought
we were talking about what Trump plans
to do when he gets into office that was
all sorry I misread three episodes back
as well which is a fine a fine listen uh
Peter let's get into the
aforementioned weird economy because
it's been kind of weirdly great at least
the numbers that have crossed over the
transom last Friday there was a jobs
report scorching jobs report according
to CNBC or Reuters or one of these
places um they all just pce each other's
headlines anyways 353,000 jobs way above
what we expected growth High inflation
not so high Etc and yet Peter Sudan you
had the
tarity to have a uh uh an article and
reason magazine cover story big feature
cover story uh and I'm going to compare
two headlines first headlines from axios
last week us winning world economic War
the United States economy grew faster
than any other large Advanced economy
last year by a wide margin and is on
track to do so again in 2024 says axios
and they've got bullet points uh Peters
is the bankruptcy of Biden omics Biden's
economic policies gave us three years of
excessive wastel and poor targeted
federal spending who's right Peter you
or the bullet points well the bullet
points are they're Breezy and easy to
read and so I I would encourage you to
just stick with them no the there are
two ways to think about the Biden
economy and biomics and one is that uh
many economic on based on many economic
fundamentals the American economy is in
reasonably good shape and I would just
say that the two big uh the two big
stats there are the jobs uh our jobs and
inflation inflation has come way down
from its peak in the summer of 2022 and
it's now uh somewhere in the range of 3%
which is not nothing but is H but is
just far down from the 9% or so
annualized inflation that we we were
seeing in 2022 and then you have these
consistently good jobs reports this is
actually one reason uh at least part of
the reason I think we have some of the
chaos at the border is because the job
market in the United States especially
for lower skilled labor is actually
quite good and so if you just look at
the state of the economy I think it's
fair to say that the American economy is
doing pretty well but Joe Biden spent
much of 2023 touring the country trying
to convince people that the economy was
great not just on the merits but because
of the policies that he had passed
starting with the uh American Rescue
plan at the beginning of 2021 which was
a two trillion doll bill passed on a
partisan basis so just Democratic votes
and the infl then the inflation
reduction act and then the chips and
science act uh which followed both of
those but all of these were big spending
policies and Biden wants to say well
those are the things that caused the
economy to be great if you start with
the American Rescue plan that was a$2
trillion like I said partisan plan that
contributed to the rise in inflation and
people said this is going to cause
inflation but Joe Biden wanted to hand
out checks and he wanted to hand out a
bunch of money to uh
constituencies Donald Trump had handed
out checks to most Americans the year
before Biden wanted had had campaigned
on that and it said before he be he went
into office well we're going to give
everybody money too so he wanted to do
that and guess what that what happened
as a result we had uh we had record
inflation the highest inflation levels
in 40 years and then after that we have
the inflation reduction Act and the
chips and science act well the inflation
reduction act no one actually thinks
that it's really about reducing
inflation no one including Joe Biden so
there was a little missed uh remark from
from Biden about a year after it passed
he was at a fundraiser you can go to the
white house uh report on this and see
his remarks in which he said he pointed
to a big chunk of money in the inflation
reduction act like it's not about refl
reducing inflation at all actually it's
just about subsidizing the biggest
whatever something or other the biggest
amount of money that we've ever put into
fighting climate change and S and
pushing Green Technology stuff like EVS
right stuff like uh EV charging stations
no one has ever never ever spent that
that is a real Biden quote that he was
bragging about and I think that that
quote is so telling and you can just
it's so revealing about the the Biden
approach to the economy it's no one has
ever ever spent that and then you Flash
Forward another year to the end of
2023 um and Sor sorry that's not a full
year you flash forward to the end of
2023 and you see these reports about how
none of these charging stations have
been built it's actually at this point I
think a handful of them have in fact
been built bu but most of the states
don't even have plans for building them
Biden is apparently complaining to his
staff that none of the stuff that he had
hoped to pose in front of in 2024 while
he was campaigning it hasn't been built
yet and you know why it hasn't been
built yeah it's very sad it's very sad
bid we spent all of this money to build
stuff on the promise that we were gonna
we were going to build things and do big
things in America again and guess what
happened we spent all of that money and
there's nothing to stand in front of
there's nothing to show for it and part
of the reason is because Joe Biden
imposed all of these uh all of these
policies that uh these requirements on
that spending you had uh you know
manufacturers if you're going to build a
factory you got to also provide on-site
Child Care uh right the the EVS have
bamerican rules that they suspended
because they weren't working there's
just all of this all all of these
requirements that slow everything down
and mean that we're spending a ton of
money we don't have a we don't have a
whole lot to show for it and that's what
bomic the policy agenda actually is a
lot of spending and not much to show for
it I just hope that our uh that our
Windows have been weatherized by now uh
through his heroic work on the I
appreciate that you are like I'm not
going to let go you never forget you're
never forget on the weather recovery
through retrofit weather it learn it
love it I got to tell you new Windows
though are pretty fantastic if you are
still living in like you know shudder
and Sh s sash type stuff it's like it's
a whole world is based on the occasional
Sirens that I hear in the background of
this podcast it does not seem like the
window
weatherization has proceeded fully I'm
I'm pretty sure my the windows in my uh
apartment are from like the first FDR
Administration or something they were
built during the Triangle shirt waist
factory fire uh Nick um I stepped on
your line earlier making a comparative
with uh Donald J Trump I would invite
you to uh to maybe look at that again
and uh are there
areas besides idiotic gigantic across
theboard tariffs um proposed tariffs
even in excess of the ones that Biden
has kept around from Trump um in which
Trump compared to Biden nomics seems
clearly better in your eyes uh no not
particularly uh or or in in this sense
there was slow and steady growth
throughout his uh presidency up till
covid uh you know I'm convinced by David
Stockman's critique who I uh the former
Reagan budget director who I interviewed
a couple weeks ago in New York it's up
online at reason and YouTube and stuff
but you know that Trump really you know
growth could have been much bigger under
Trump if he hadn't been such an idiot as
well as his covid policies were terrible
and he was the cheerleader for lockdown
so we should remember all of that and
also giving large sums of money Biden
expanded continued and expanded a lot of
that stuff what worries me as much as
anything right now about the weird
economy that you're talking about Matt
is just said labor labor force
participation rate is flat from a year
ago so like if this economy is so great
why aren't more people working uh in in
working age situations and the in the
peak years of that from people age 25 to
54 labor force participation rate has
actually declined a bit from last
September wow uh so there's something
funky going on and I mean I I'm trying
not to just you know be like okay well
we have to be contrarian because Biden's
policies are terrible so the outcomes
must be terrible but there is a palpable
sense of you know dread or Gloom or
uncertainty and what this is reminding
me of in a lot of ways is you know it's
partly because it's an election year and
we have the two shittiest choices in
front of us since 2020 and
2016 um and you know people are going to
be kind of like everybody is kind kind
of waiting to see what happens and it's
not even necessarily because I want my
guy to win but it's like there will be a
pause after the election or or a slight
return to normaly once we know but I
don't think the economy is as good as
people are you know as as much as the
headlines are trying to say and I think
you can also see a crank up in Legacy
Media in particular of like no really
the economy is not just good it's great
we are winning the World War Matt axio
says so um you know so I think there
something here we're going to see
whatever English can be put on this ball
in a Biden uh mode is going to it's it's
going to be there core inflation is
still which is uh inflation absent
energy and food is still at about 4% uh
which is down from a peak of six almost
7% a couple years ago but it's also
substantially higher than it was before
the pandemic so people are feeling a
pinch and we've kind of result you know
we've kind of nestled into a new normal
that is not good you know it's not as
good as it was so there's lots of
reasons to be nervous about the uh the
economy on the labor force participation
point it's just worth noting that the
pandemic pulled a lot of people out the
out of the labor force just because
things closed or things were forced to
close just the economy got very weird
during 2020 but then what happened was
under both Trump and then Biden in 2021
there were payments made to most
Americans uh and those payments swelled
bank accounts you saw the highest rate
of savings in 2021 and then going into
2022 uh in in decades maybe ever um and
what that did was it made it easier for
people to not re-enter the labor force
and one thing we know about work is that
the longer you are out of work the
longer you don't work the less likely
you are to come back to work and so part
of what they did was subsidize
worklessness I like that word
worklessness well and there's also a
long-term Readjustment going on in the
economy uh the labor force participation
rate peaked in uh 202 uh 2000 roughly at
67% it's about 62 and a. half% overall
and it's been pretty flat like it hasn't
been able to get back up to where it was
for many years so that's also something
that's happening here there's a there's
a very long-term economic uh
restructuring going on and that is
worrying because we got to get to
whatever the new economy is and it feels
like we're in a kind of sits Creek if
we're going to keep going with the uh
War metaphors uh Katherine and yet isn't
axios correct the United States economy
grew faster than any other large
Advanced economy last year by wide
margin and we'll do again this year is
it possible the Libertarians just love
to complain and maybe it's all fine
because America those things are all
true Libertarians do love to complain I
spent the the weekend at the uh students
for Liberty annual conference Liberty
con and there was deed some complaining
though I will say uh it was an
international crowd and so uh the
Americans complaints did immediately
pale and comparison right it was like
things are so bad here and people were
like um I'm from Venezuela you know what
I mean so there was that um and there is
you know there is there is this element
of Truth which is like the American
economy still has these just incredible
you know World historically
unprecedented strengths and so uh and so
we do have that but um
I I
think this is less about attempting to
find out a true answer about the
strength or weaknesses of the US economy
and just more about how these jerks are
running for office and so it's just 100%
motivated reasoning uh so much of this
debate is what are the words I can say
that will help my team the most and um
those of us don't have a team who don't
have a team can can do our best to
figure it out in between but I think
saying you are wrong everything is fine
uh when people like come home with their
little small bag of groceries that used
to you know that cost them as much as
what used to be four bags of groceries
is not I struggle to believe that's
going to be an effective electoral
strategy and uh and I think we should
pay attention to little scary corners of
the economy even if some of the big
numbers are good in fact as Biden toward
the country making the case for biomics
last year he kept saying well this is
biomics in action it's working it's
working and if you looked at the polling
on trust in his ability to handle the
economy from the middle of 2023 through
the end of 2023 which is basically the
period of time in which he was making
that case it actually got worse it
started bad and it got worse and Biden's
job approval rating has not really
recovered here uh in the last six weeks
even as we have seen some small shifts
in consumer sentiment Katherine please
tell me that there were some uh AA
shirts at Liberty con uh in fact uh one
of the groups that received
um received a prize during the dinner on
Saturday night was um a group from
Argentina and um you know they they were
they were enthused they were bringing a
lot of aera to the situation they had a
flag you know and it was it you don't
see those kind of Vibes at libertarian
conferences necessarily but uh I yeah
they were really uh uh abiant and
exciting and toxic it was great I
actually uh got home and was talking
with my family about the conference and
end we ended up in a situation where I
was showing my children a photo of
Javier M with the chainsaw and uh and my
daughter said wait so like a
Libertarian is in charge of a country
with this like incredible incredulity in
her voice and I was like that's fair
that's fair all right we're going to get
to our listener uh email of the week
here in a moment but first the world
would be a better Freer and happier
place if the Constitution's pre-existing
protections for private property were
taken more seriously that's why our Pals
over the institute for justice American
Heroes they have released a new season
of their hit legal History Podcast Bound
by oath Bound by oath tells the story of
how the Supreme Court has cleared the
way for government officials to abuse
property rights to trespass on private
land without a warrant to restrict
peaceful and productive uses of property
it's okay to hiss by the way uh to seize
and keep property without sufficient
justification and many more outrages
featuring interviews not only with
Scholars and litigators but also with
the real life people behind some of the
Supreme Court's most notorious property
rights decisions the new season explores
the history behind today's civil rights
battles please do look up Bound by oath
wherever you get your podcasts it's
bound by oath Institute for justice
property rights hissing do it today
you'll be glad you did thank you Nick
for that all right reminder to email
your or to the point uh queries to
Roundtable reason.com this one comes
from Chris giri who writes I'd like your
thoughts on the idea that to improve our
Collective sensemaking it should become
a norm for at least all non opinion news
outlets to require their journalists to
disclose their voting records reason
does did he says something similar yes
uh and I think uh this would be
immensely helpful in at least four ways
one it provides the reader with
information that's important context to
the story the postmodern consideration
two it establishes a baseline of trust
between journalist and recipient I'm
putting my cards on the table three it
would encourage the journalist to try to
be more balanced in reporting because
Jero knows what bias reader will be
looking for so Journal will want to
proactively counter it and for it would
hopefully shame the publisher into
seeking out and hiring journalists with
different outlooks which Jonathan Rouch
tells us is necessary for the
constitution of knowledge to actually
work I'm sure there would be downsides
too but thoughts I have many of thoughts
we'll get to them but Katherine do you
want to lead off yes so uh you're the
letter writer is correct reason does do
this has been doing this for a long time
and uh especially points one and two are
mostly the reasons we do it um I am
deeply skeptical that point four has
very much power uh because the other
publication that has done this uh in the
past with some consistency although I
don't think they do it anymore is slate
um where they're like um they make
Academia look ideologically
diverse it's it's really something um
and people don't have any Shame about it
I mean this is we have these findings
over and over and over in all of our
Elite institutions that they are
overwhelmingly not just kind of um
philosophically liberal in disposition
but
democratically partisan uh at at a over
90% level you know everywhere absolutely
everywhere and uh no one no one seems to
be embarrassed no one is ashamed um you
know reason does it um we will probably
do it again and uh when we do it a bunch
of people are going to get their panties
and a bunch about it um because someone
on our because everybody had reason
votes for Norman Thomas right staff is
going to vote a way that they don't like
and uh even even if in their text of
their explanation they say this is the
most grudging possible vote this is
being dragged from me by Wild Horses
only due to a a tiny uh reason why this
person is marginally less bad than the
other person or whatever um the you know
brain poisoning of partisanship is so
bad that people will say look I added up
all the votes and you know there was one
Biden voter and two Trump voters and
everyone else basically just screamed ah
into their answer but um you know that
means that reason endorsed Donald Trump
right and that's that's I wish that
people wouldn't do that because I don't
think that's the point of the exercise
but um what I think is the point doesn't
matter the whole idea of it is you put
it out there and people do with this
information what they will so if I may
uh Matt I want to thank you for
introducing that awful feature to reason
uh that came in when you darkened our
door and uh pushed uh me as editor of
the print magazine at the time to do it
what I found most interesting about the
um about the the way we do it at reason
was that you know people also talked
about previous votes uh and then uh some
other question and that we bring in
people in our universe that you wouldn't
necessarily hear about so it could be
pendulette or you know cartoonist Peter
bag or or thinkers like Stuart brand
people who are adjacent to us and that
it just becomes an interesting
discussion of what's going on during a
presidential election year but also what
is a wide range of people you know who
are they voting for and why that could
be kind of interesting I think what the
uh letter writer is getting at and this
is a very different question at the New
York Times or you know the Wall Street
Journal or the Washington Post or you
know media that pretends to be
objective um that would be genuinely
fascinating even if they just tabulated
uh without giving the names they could
anonymize the data and just say you know
what like we pulled X number of staffers
who write on a daily basis and this
these this is the breakdown of who's
voting for whom or who's not voting I've
met uh and I'm struggling to remember
any of their names but that's because
I'm struggling to remember all names at
this point in my life but I've met a
bunch of like you know
high-profile Legacy Media journalists
who say I don't vote um because I would
be compromised somehow I think that's
stupid but I kind of respect that but I
I would love to see this I don't I don't
think it it it can be interesting as a
feature in Publications like slate if
they were ever interesting and it can be
interesting it is interesting in reason
style Publications but the most
interesting thing would be in these
other objective groups and I would like
to see that become a norm I do love the
weird reversal of cause and effect that
comes in um that comes in that line that
you just mentioned Nick like I don't
hear it as much anymore more uh and I
guess I never thought I would miss it
but now I do but it it was a very very
common thing for a journalist to say I
don't vote
because that would bias me um which is
both like what no like the bias would
certainly pre-exist the vote if you were
biased but also is true like it also is
true that like if you commit to
something then you then you are more
likely to seek out its positive
attributes and downplay its negative
attributes like it's like a weirdly deep
psychological insight that I think
people are just saying in a stupid way
um so but I I now am retroactively
nostalgic for the days when at least
some journalists said that because now
uh almost every journalist at a
publication that would describe itself
as objective is in fact going to vote
for Joe Biden and many of them will
believe that not doing so represents an
existential threat um to the country and
to their own profession the other
variation on this which is good for a
laugh um is when uh the nation used to
do this all the time where they would in
every election there would be a
socialist a green party somebody who
embodied everything they stood for often
named Ralph nater and they would always
say Ralph we agree with you
10,000% but this election is too
important to vote for the person who
perfectly encapsulates what we believe
so would you please drop out so we can
vote for a candidate that we Lo
ideologically but obviously support with
every fiber of our being and they just
do that on an almost regular basis which
is kind of funny The Intercept published
that exact piece about seven or eight
days ago without necessarily lionizing
you know Cornell West and and Jill Stein
but um saying you know it's oh what a
team to uh two could they be
co-presidents you know that would just
that's so perfect uh but uh was going to
say Katherine that I am my lifelong not
belonging to a political party is
totally out of that same impulse like I
don't want to join anything cuz I write
about this stuff um and also because I'm
not the Joiner of things at all uh Peter
because you're a moral coward Matt come
on thank you I just want to note that we
now have uh we got a letter uh I
received a letter from one of our
listeners um noting that tomorrow if you
live in Nevada you
can vote for none of the above that is
now an option it's been that way for
about you you uh in fact in the
Democratic primary if um if the none of
these candidates pick reaches 15% that
delegates representing that perspective
will go to the nominating convention
Unbound to any candidate want to say
things are looking great for none of the
above right now um so maybe that's a way
to get around all of this uh you know
bias hacking that this is like how at at
worldcon for a couple of years the big
science fiction convention where they
award the Hugo Awards which is maybe the
biggest award in science fiction for a
couple of years after a big controversy
involving a a group called the S puppies
I won't explain it here Google it or
maybe maybe don't maybe just go touch
grass but uh yeah for a for a couple of
years some of the big awards were won by
No
Award uh I immediately heard that as
some dude named Noah I'm like so um yeah
Noah award I love his book he's fine
writer nothing wrong with him my brother
actually love his substack touch grass
but not the yellow grass is the uh is
the idea don't eat the yellow grass so
just briefly I I think I I I would not
mind this becoming a Norm at the same
time I don't think the salutory effects
that the writer suggests uh would be all
that strong salutary uh right Sal the
the good effects the positive ones um
and I think there would be a couple of
things one is the thing that that Nick
already mentioned is that you would
probably or possibly have an incentive
for many journalists to Simply stop
voting and that way they could pretend
they are not biased right they could say
well look I don't vote and that allows
me to not be biased and that wouldn't be
the case they would still have their
biases um another thing at least they
wouldn't be voting and Katherine would
be very happy about that uh Nick would
not be very happy about that but it
wouldn't end up revealing or shaping the
conversation on the other hand if they
did say oh well here's my voting record
then I think another that something that
would happen is especially with news
reports non opinion pieces which is what
this listener is talking about you would
end up with news reports that are that
are in fact true being totally dismissed
because of someone's uh background and
you see this already to some extent
right with with the New York Times oh
this is in the New York Times we can't
believe it and they don't provide a
reason why it's wrong nobody they don't
provide a reason that this is false or
that is it is lacking context it's just
it's in the New York Times we don't
believe it and that I think ultimately
is my sort of big picture not objection
to this but the reason why I don't think
that this would solve as much as the
writer hopes it's because everyone knows
that the vast vast majority of staffers
at the New York Times and CNN and the
other big news Gathering Outlets the
vast majority of them at least 70 and
possibly 98% of the editorial staffers
are are are left leaning somehow or
another vote Democratic their their
hearts are with the Democratic party and
that's something that we already know
and I don't think this would change that
I think the the lopsidedness of the
numbers are always really interesting
Katherine mentioned slate I think it was
in
2016 um one of those years uh when they
revealed the numbers were 59 one and one
and one was for libertarian and one was
for Evan McMullen so yeah that's it's
not 59% % folks 59 out of
61 everybody I tried to get this uh done
at the LA times when I worked in the
opinion section and the the uh those
objections were brought up like oh you
know people will all say this and what
whatever about us and that would be
terrible um and I I think it has the
most salutary effect not on on the
reader uh listener or whatever uh but on
the institution if I was running a uh
institution that that claimed at all to
to be like impartial in its Gathering of
information and transmission having to
do with controversial political issues
um gy I would like to know if it was a
591 in one because then be like oh U
that gets to uh the letter writers
number four I believe um it won't
actually shame anyone my I write a
column every four years attempting to
shame my journalistic colleagues uh for
not following our trailblazing lead of
20 years now and standing and each year
I try a different attack I think one
that I'm going to use this year is
journalists have been boring us to tears
in the Trump era about how like
objectivity is pass a what we need is
moral Clarity we need to write about
when we're talking about politics no
stop talking about the odds talk about
the stakes mean everything is we need a
pro-democracy desk we need to let people
know that fascism is coming around the
corner and all of this if you really
believe all this and I'll take you at
your word for the moment that you do
then don't you owe it to everybody to
just argue like yes not just I'm voting
for Joe Biden but yes exclamation point
because I'm not a fascist yes you need
to do this like wear it wear it on your
sleeve if you are so like mad about the
alleged view from nowhere um that uh
Legacy journalistic institutions have
allegedly embraced over the years then
you should be championing this even more
than we do um because it's transparency
it's building trust and it's saying yeah
this is where we're at um so why don't
you have that confidence cuz you're
cowards that's why you don't have the
confidence all right uh last Wednesday
the chief Executives of meta which owns
Facebook uh Tik Tok
snap Discord and Twitter snap crank yeah
come here snap CEO what we're Westside
Story social network
right they're hold up to Congress yet
again uh to confess their sins of
running a tech business uh this time
it's from the the Senate Judiciary
Committee as ever whenever the senior
citizens and IV League populists attempt
to browbeat purveyors of Technology um
the comedy and cringe levels were uh way
past 11 uh so let's each go through uh
and uh rather quickly uh uh single out a
low light Nick why don't you start uh so
for me both the lowl light and the
Highlight uh was when Josh Holly uh
forced an apology uh from Mark
Zuckerberg who really never should have
stopped wearing the zinc oxide Sun you
know sunscreen I think that was a good
look for him and he should always appear
in public in that just to scare people
but uh Holly uh said you know you have
to apologize for all of the people that
you have harmed and all the harm you
have done through Facebook all the
children you have killed uh Etc and
Zuckerberg you know St hammered out an
apology and then he's like well are you
going to compensate them uh and it was
like first off as bad as Congress is
right and I mean they suck upper lower
house it doesn't matter but then
Zuckerberg like how you know are
witnesses that stupid like they keep
falling for this I would have loved to
have seen uh uh Zuckerberg uh push back
and said well are you going to apologize
for letting uh Tor Sanders Killers off
the hook who was a guy who was killed
uh you know by cops or sheriffs in
Missouri and when Holly was AG let it
slide um blaming it on excited delirium
which is a delusional fake uh medical
diagnosis but I I'm just for me that was
the thing and this this is the shape of
things to come uh you know big Tech has
created the grounds for a symbiotic
relationship with the government and it
means that they're going to have to be
whipping boys publicly and then they
will get get the regulation that they
want Facebook has been calling to be
regulated since
2018 uh Instagram you can't go on
Instagram without seeing ads about how
we need to regulate ourselves better
blah blah blah but it's just sickening
uh Katherine low
light I really enjoyed the um Tom Cotton
interaction with the CEO of tiktock
where he was like hey hi I'm from
Singapore and Tom Cotton was like have
you a member of the Chinese Communist
party and he was
like once again I am from Singapore and
it just kept going and I I actually
think you know this is one of those
great examples of
like the little clip made it
seem worse than it was like Tom Cotton
was trying to make a point deeply
ineptly about Tik tok's entanglements
with the Chinese government and with the
Chinese Communist Party um Mis begotten
though it
was even so it was so spectacularly
stupid it was such an incredible
unforced error and uh my longstanding
belief that Tom Cotton is one of the
most poisonous people on Capitol Hill uh
was certainly bolstered by this
interaction um I always love moments in
these hearings when and they happen
every single time when one of the tech
CEOs has the opportunity to just Riley
State an obviously true fact that
highlights how stupid and Grand standy
the Senators are being um yeah this is
like the classic you know what why
doesn't my iPhone work and it's like
Senator I work for Google like there's
like that kind of thing uh is always uh
is always a nice moment so thank you Tom
Cotton for providing that one to us this
time around he's the fabric of Our Lives
Tom Cotton uh Peter uh like s's in The
Hourglass what did you uh what did you
enjoy well the thing that jumped out at
me wasn't any specific bit so much as it
was that Elizabeth Nolan Brown was
really really right back in uh May of
2023 she wrote a piece titled
childproofing the Internet it's a great
piece and it basically argues that all
of the regulatory stuff that Congress
wants to do has wanted to do has kind of
not quite been able to do for the last
decade in terms of regulating the
internet in terms of setting rules for
social for big tech companies and social
media companies all of that stuff is
finally going to be justified on the
argument that this stuff hurts children
and the regulations won't just protect
children and in fact they probably won't
really protect children at all what they
will do is make life tough for these
companies make the internet worse make
the internet experience worse for a
bunch of adults and possibly even make
it less safe and uh and create privacy
flaws and holes and uh you know sort of
just mess things up in ways that are not
productive at all and so this is this
hearing was uh was unfortunately
Vindication for the Elizabeth Nolan
Brown childproofing the internet theory
of Internet regulation I generally
believe with apologies to people on this
podcast that um no one should ever write
a non-fiction book with a through line
of argumentation and they should always
only just write it as a long form
magazine article but the how socer
explains Katherine mangu Ward exactly
the one time that I almost wrote a book
was going to a book that was just a
history of using it's for the children
to do horrific authoritarian and uh
instead I got pregnant and just produced
a child instead of the book and that was
you manifested it was the right call but
I enjoy the I told penguin the old uh
the great old kids only social media
site I think that ruined a generation of
children pretty clearly I don't know you
know it it U the game uh you know
puffing sales everywhere and every way
shap and former way up so it's that in
Mortal Kombat my uh favorite terrible
moment uh at the hearings was every time
uh John Kennedy we have a John Kennedy
in the Senate I don't know why Republic
it's by
Statute the framers wanted a John
Kennedy in in the Senate every quote out
of his mouth was a reason why we need a
constitutional amendment to Bar people
named John Kennedy and just Kennedy
maybe in general unless it's MTV's
Kennedy uh from government greatest
Kennedy he said
uh you're in the foothills of
creepy welan metaphor yeah that's why I
liked it uh ask Eli Roth movie waiting
to be made does your user agreement
still suck was one question from him uh
he accused uh Facebook uh of uh doing a
killing field of
information wow where user because users
only see one side of is
like okay um and on and on and on but uh
the worst was or the most hilarious one
was this attempted burn to uh Mark
Zuckerberg you have convinced over two
billion people to give up all of their
personal information every bit of it in
exchange for getting to see what their
high school friends had for dinner
Saturday night it's like yeah I'm pretty
I'm pretty awesome aren't I I convince
people to do that and they were
perfectly willing to do it theu that you
guys are always making 2 billion
Americans do and now
we'll billion people
globally Matt uh remember that uh John
Kennedy is in the senator diaper seat so
you know we have lower expectations he
replaced David Vitter uh who had an
untimely demise that is always worth
remembering because that's who's running
the country people like David vider uh
let's get to our end of podcast what we
have all been consuming uming in the
cultural Arena Catherine wanted you lead
us off I would love to so last week uh
after I um gave a little Manifesto
little speech about how I'm really just
going on uh none of the above this year
uh which I've already delivered on this
podcast uh Brian Brushwood a internet
personality of some Fame tweeted at me
that I should uh therefore watch the
movie Brewsters millions and this is a
uh 1985
movie that um I immediately downloaded
and started to watch and the first sound
in this movie is the crack of a bat
heating hitting a baseball and I was
like I've been fooled I've been tricked
into watching a baseball movie um did
you hear that sound in Dolby Atmos I
heard it on my little earbuds watching
on my phone on the Metro so no um but I
uh persevered pleas I kept going and in
fact uh it is a delightful movie that is
not really about baseball at all um but
instead about um among other things the
incredible power uh of a noneof the
above ticket uh there's a beautiful
scene in which uh our hero is rallying
an enormous crowd of people who are
wearing sashes and holding signs and
carrying banners that all say uh none of
the above in response to uh just a
horrific political choices Peter what
did you consume I watched Argy the
Matthew vau directed wouldbe comic spy
Blockbuster and I say would be
Blockbuster because this movie cost $200
million or at least that is what Apple
paid for it uh as a sort of not quite
direct to streaming but a a sort of
streaming primarily property and this is
a movie by the guy who directed layer
cake and the kingsman films all of which
were kind of very interestingly
libertarian movies layer cake is a a
movie about the futility of the drug war
you see that again in the second
Kingsman film the first Kingsman film
and the is really about sort of the
bankruptcy of liberal Global Elites the
third one is a a kind of it's It's a
less successful movie but it's a really
righteous and angry film about the cost
of war and just how much it damages
people and how stupid and futile it is
and how governments force people into
war and it just makes the world a much
worse place makes life less worth living
and sadly Argyle doesn't have any of
those themes and it is mostly a misfire
over long not very funny even the very
creative action sequences that pop up at
the end just kind of don't land because
the pacing is all off Sam Rockwell and
Dallas Bryce Bryce Dallas Howard are the
stars here it's they're kind of funny
Sam Rockwell in particular is a very
underrated actor but unfortunately this
movie movie just doesn't work and it's
really a it's really a shame coming from
a director who has often been so so much
fun but also so righteously political in
big budget popular filmmaking Nick what
did you consum I watched uh what I guess
is HBO's Sunday night lineup uh although
I watched it on Max uh the app and I
have no idea where you know any of this
is actually taking place anymore but I
watched Curb Your Enthusiasm the first
episode of season 12 the final season of
Cur Your Enthusiasm which is very good
and as always it it has a reprise of
various Seinfeld related themes which
shows why Seinfeld may have replaced the
Godfather as the Earth text of the
Contemporary you know the way that The
Godfather was everybody was doing
something related to The Godfather from
the time it came out until Saddam
Hussein who used to wear the hat that
Michael Corleone wore in public
appearances you know since he was his
regime change came to him uh but kerb
Your Enthusiasm uh it it was a very good
start to an episode and kind of a
further deconstruction of Larry David
and almost everything that is good and
decent in American culture and then I'm
I also am uh there have been four of six
episodes for True Detective uh season 4
which is called night country uh that
features Jody Foster and uh kie Reese
and uh it's set in Alaska it's not done
by the original uh showrunner and
whatnot but it had a scene in it that I
shrieked like a little girl it's a very
spooky scary it's kind of it's kind of
True Detective meets John Carpenter's
The Thing and it's a very uh slow moving
buildup show uh there are two episodes
left and I think it's going to be pretty
great and what I was think when I the
reason I watch these in tandem is I can
remember a time in the late 90s and
early 2000s when The Sopranos Sex in the
City Curb Your Enthusiasm were on Sunday
nights on HBO they went with you know
it's not TV it's HBO and The Sopranos at
the very least was actually beating out
broadcast network shows for audience
share and it's fascinating to me to
think neither of these shows has a
market anywhere close to that most of
the people aren't even watching it on
HBO people have continued to cut cable
nobody watches broadcast TV in any kind
of meaningful way the way we used to so
they it's kind of a world of Wonders
these are both excellent programs in and
of themselves but kind of the way in
which we consume culture continues to
get better and better even if it means
we get to consume more and more stuff
even if their market share is smaller
and smaller and I actually think that's
a a very nice positive outcome for
producers and consumers as well so we
are past Peak television just in terms
of the number of scripted shows that are
being produced it is actually down
somewhat on the other hand Even in our
post Peak television era there have to
be at least five if not close to 10
times as many scripted shows as were
being produced in the early 1990s uh
maybe even the late 1990s when there
were fewer than 50 or 60 scripted
television shows being produced period
each year was really amazing just to
look at the volume and the way that the
scripted TV Market has expanded and it's
I mean when to say on this a little bit
because I do think it's important and
you know we live in a different world
our economy hasn't fully caught up we
haven't moved into whatever comes after
the the end of the Cold War kind of and
the end of the war on terror the global
war on terror but culturally we're also
consuming very different things and so
you know when you factor in YouTube and
not just reality TV but uh you know
shows like The Joe Rogan Experience
whether you're listening to it or
watching clip or whatever it's just you
know we talked a lot I certainly did at
reason in the 9s about the proliferation
of culture and a kind of In Praise of
cultural chaos and Anarchy and it's here
and it's pretty great um even as you
start to hear now as people get more and
more anxious and nostalgic they're like
oh where are the water cooler shows blah
blah you know and it's like they're not
here because we've been we've been freed
we don't have to watch one or two things
you know at a given time you know that
are kind of forced on us we you know we
can do what we want and we still have
plenty to talk about in common the
future is the reason Roundtable in
glorious HD
video uh so I watched a water cooler uh
moment yesterday I tuned into the last
two hours of the Grammy Awards which
yeah these days it's not a water cooler
Matt it's that's you're in a Stanley
thermal mug and you're nobody nobody
watches this anymore relative to the
Past right comparatively it's still a
moment uh that was large enough to drive
Tracy Chapman's 1988 song fast car to
number one on iTunes and the album to
number one on iTunes based on her
performance of the song with Luke Colmes
country star um he had done a cover last
summer that launched a thousand
absolutely idiotic I don't want to say
think pieces brain fart pieces absence
of thought pieces yeah uh in the
Washington Post in the Atlantic in every
single place that certain people have
worked um just awful um The Washington
Post one was like you know the
complicated response to the a fast car
you know it's it's renewing difficult
conversations it's like or or hear me
out on this one a guy really liked the
song and he did a really good version of
it it got popular and Tracy Chapman was
super stoked about it herself and the
performance last night was lovely uh the
Grammy Awards have uh transitioned into
a live like mashup concert uh over the
years so every year I like to sort of
tune in and then one out of the
performances works for me and this was
the one and um it did create quite a
viral moment that people responded to
you can uh we'll send a link to it um
Trace trapal was awesome she looked
great she played great um and there's
this wonderful overflowing sense of like
gratitude accomplishment just everything
uh coursing through uh just her face
that she was playing it was a it was a
wonderful uh moment and an absolute
repudiation in my opinion of every
idiotic uh cultural appropriation or
whatever uh uh kind of cultural argument
that's made in music and in food the two
places where everything should be
appropriated all the time and just is
lovely and it's mixed and it's great um
that's the whole point of everything um
so I loved it on its own and I also
loved it um because it just shows that
the Atlantic and the Washington Post can
go right up kiss your grits Matt they go
touch grass no you know what was great
about that too is like I watched that
like minutes after it happened without
having to watch the Grammys so it was
you know everything was kind of dish
intermediated so you can watch it um I
also saw that I remember I was working
at smash hits the American version of
Smash Hits when Tracy Chapman's album
came out and I was like this is a
great record and it was seen as
an angry record and it is an angry
record but it's just beautiful and what
was most interesting about the
performance is she was happy and smiling
and jubilant and in a weird way that's a
dark song but it kind of wow like we're
in a better place when that is happening
at the Grammys and she is putting a full
stop on all of this stupidity that you
were talking about that's gorgeous all
right that's all the uh the gorgeousness
we have time for on the reason Round
Table podcast videoast um thank you for
tuning in all of our podcasts are
available at reason.com
podcasts uh Believe It or Not uh if you
like what we do you can donate to the
nonprofit that publishes all of our
stuff that's the reason Foundation go to
reason.com donate and otherwise we shall
see you next week
goodbye se you
trying
your